calling it a non-profit music education
group doesn't quite really capture what
they're all about even though it's
technically what it is yeah maybe
spreading joy through music a better
description nate tannenbaum joining us
with the story of joy the jazz outreach
initiative
when three good friends put their
musical heads together five years ago
they worked hard to get where they are
today
that includes free educational concerts
like this recent jazz for young people
at the college of southern nevada's
north las vegas campus where even
grown-ups learned a thing or two about
legendary trumpeter miles davis now the
last thing in the world his family
wanted was for miles to become a jazz
musician
the jazz outreach initiative is the
brainchild of las vegas kenny rampton
who now travels the world playing
trumpet with wynton marcellus in the
jazz at lincoln center orchestra
and gary cordell
the fella who spoke at that joy csn
concert
it is all about education our motto has
been let's make a difference kenny and
gary bonded the day they met playing in
the unlv marching band after kenny was
in both the mcdonald's all-american
marching and jazz bands at bonanza high
school
as both have grown in their careers and
we feel the pull to you know to give
back for so many doors and opportunities
that were open for us i came through
vegas several years ago with jazlyn
center orchestra we played the smith
center and i did a q a we had like 250
kids show up and i was so moved by these
kids
i was just thinking the rest of the day
like man i want to do something for my
hometown
and so there's buzzing in brass a joy
program that shows elementary kids they
already know music even if they might
think their brains are
in that area
on a more serious note executive
director donnie thompson is proud of
joy's jazz roots program there's a lot
of organizations that provide music
instruments to kids who will never have
access to them but we went a step
farther and brought in members of the
community to also pay for a year worth
of free private lessons they've
partnered with music and arts the
nation's largest music store retailer
music and arts jim winslow i couldn't
think of a better way to start our 70th
year in business by partnering with jazz
outreach initiative and the lessons are
paying off instructor professional
saxophonist eddie rich with budding
saxophonists ileana
[Music]
all right
that is so awesome truly spreading joy
in our community you want to learn more
about the jazz outreach initiative
they're on facebook we've got a link to
that and their website on
eightnewsnow.com nathan tanenbaum live
local now